friends how do we alleviate
psychological suffering how do we
alleviate human suffering
the diseases of Despair the pathologies
of mental anguish are no joke
characterized by excessive
self-consciousness and excessive
rumination things like anxiety panic
disorder depression post-traumatic
stress disorder can really arrest our
vitality and send us straight to
hell I have direct experience of what
it's like to be in the throngs of
psychological suffering I know
post-traumatic stress disorder I know
what it is to
be so agitated by perpetual
hypervigilance and Relentless
self-monitoring that the intrusive
thoughts that are triggering
physiological anxiety become your lived
experience it's difficult to articulate
the torture of trauma you know David
lensen refers to trauma as temporal
dislocation we get stuck in the past
this traumatic experience is now brought
to the doorstep of every moment it
becomes the psychological lenses of
perception in the interpretive
Frameworks that we involuntarily coat
the world with everything is seen
through the lens of this fear that we
can't shake the problem again with
trauma or as they say the body keeps the
score is that these
this physiological stuckness is in our
tissues and it's in our mental patterns
it's in our mental patterns in the same
way that like a broken record keeps
looping on the same lyric we too
can become stuck in these mental
patterns and the solidity of adulthood
of adult thinking makes it very
difficult to shake this what is needed
and what makes psychedelic intervention
potentially so so miraculous is that
psychedelic compounds revert us to a
highly plastic state or what's called a
pivotal mental state highly plastic
states are what children are endowed
with with this kind of heightened
impression ability and a capacity for
deep learning you know when you are in a
highly plastic State not only can you be
impressed upon by the world and also
potentially traumatized but you can also
experience inverse PTSD you can learn
learn that whatever caused you trauma is
no longer a danger to you but this is
something that needs to be learned in
the body only when the mind is in a
highly plastic State and so what makes
psychotropics so miraculous is that they
engender a return to this
plasticity and in a sense bring us back
to the astounding Frontier of the
present moment the impressionability of
a child as he or she casts a fresh green
breast of a new world compelled into
aesthetic contemplation and heightened
receptivity so that finally a deep
psychological intervention can be
impressed upon the psyche can repair the
damage can bring you back to life now
I've been thinking about highly plastic
States because I am no stranger to
trauma I am no stranger to
hypervigilance I am no stranger to
Relentless self monitoring I know what
it's like to experience a panic attack I
know what it's like to to to to feel
like I can't breathe I know what it's
like to be assaulted by intrusive
thoughts I've know I've known friends
who've taken their lives because they
could not flee the darkness in their
mind and so this is personal for me more
so because I also know what it's like to
return to a state of grace and and the
kind of rest receptivity that allows me
to decouple myself from this
physiological stuckness of fear where I
can rewrite the patterns where I can
rewrite the maps where the lenses of
perception that have been tainted and
discolored and are being brought to the
doorstep of every moment can be replaced
by a new interpretive physiological
mythopoetic framework that changes
everything that silences the chatter it
kills the broken ego that brings me back
to life that off offers us a second
chance at
revivification so we can at once learn
to feel again without being afraid to
feel this is no joke friends this is
this is a matter of life and death these
diseases of Despair are taking more
lives every year than violent conflict
and armed than armed conflict and
natural disasters combined and so this
is a psychospiritual
emergency and if we don't mend our
fractures if we don't heal our
Brokenness if we don't get ourselves
into these highly plastic states where
we can go in there and make the surgical
intervention that changes the story that
we tell ourselves about ourselves well
then there's no hope for us and so my
invitation friends is
to so support the creation of
infrastructure support networks of
intervention
scale the systems
that make it easy for people
to find access to the psychological
treatments and
interventions that will give them a
second chance at life because
well no one deserves to drown in that
kind of psychological
Darkness it's not something I wish upon
anyone the torture and the anguish of a
mind that turns against itself of a
psyche that is stuck in a loop of
fear is
unimaginably
horrific
and I see hope in heightened plasticity
I see hope in heightened
impressionability I see hope in opening
ourselves to a new
story and a new framework of self-
understanding that finally steps us out
of
the the swamp in which we have been
drowning thanks for
listening